We have any suggestions for a foot bath detox unit that has no or low EMFs.
I've used some in the past they've had higher EMFs so they've had problems.
Well, I don't know if you have an EMF meter that you're measuring those EMFs,
or you just had issues of ill health when you used it. I don't know.
We don't sell a foot bath detox unit to our patients. Most of our patients have a true
right unit, and the true right unit comes with an iron pro wave, and we have tested that with
a EMF meter, and it is very low EMFs. There's no EMFs coming out of that. You can get some EMFs
coming out of the computer because it's a computer-based program. So when you hit run on the
program, whether you're using the true right with the bulb, or whether you're using the true right
with the iron pro wave, the EMFs are mainly coming out of the computer. That's why we always
suggest people to close their computer and put it to sleep, and then they don't get any EMFs.
As a standalone foot bath unit, the stand-alone units that are out there, I know Ercolia
makes a good one. I am pro-ion cleanse, who is the original, and they probably make the best one
that's out there in the market. There's a lot of stand-alone foot bath detox units.
They're out of China that I would not recommend. I've tested a few of those, and I don't think they
work very well at all, and I've had people give me theirs to try on. I just don't think they
work very well at all. So I wouldn't suggest those. I know they're far cheaper,
but I do not know that I am cleanse nor do I know if the Ercolia brand what the EMF output on those
is. I've never tested that, so I can't testify to that.